Republican congressman from Texas in
fact chip Roy member of the Judiciary
budget and rules committees uh you know
they're just no words and and this seems
so preventable because we know five
times he was deported that means
somebody had eyes on him five times
yeah Harris like like this is the
reality what we're dealing with in Texas
and we keep trying to make this point to
all of America to understand in Texas in
the last decade we've had 261
000 illegal immigrants carry out about
430 something thousand crimes including
800 murders 800 kidnappings and about 5
000 assaults this is something we're
dealing with all the time I mean think
about those numbers and here we've got
somebody who's deported five times we
have border patrol overwhelmed eyes
overwhelmed cartels empowered fentanyl
killing 72 000 Americans including the
five or six kids in the school district
in the county in which I live but also
the migrants let's remember this
eight-year-old nine-year-old boy some
people are saying oh these are the you
know illegal immigrants who were killed
in this house I don't know if I think
one might have been a citizen that
doesn't matter this is an eight-year-old
boy a nine-year-old boy like what are we
doing in the most powerful history a
country in the history of the world
we're allowing this to occur it's all
largely preventable if we would just
reclaim operational control of our
border and I'm proud that Republicans in
the house to share committee put across
legislation two weeks ago that would
take a giant step toward doing that I
hope we will move it off the house floor
next week when we get back to coincide
with title 42 expiring all relevant to
what we're dealing with right now when
border patrol will continue to be
overwhelmed and now massively more
overwhelmed with the expiration of title
42. well I quote you all the time I mean
you said it's time for Republicans to
put up or shut up like you you've got to
go forward you've got to have a plan now
uh and and with regard to how many 261
000 committing more than 400 000 crimes
should we be shocked the initial crime
is coming around those checkpoints and
entering our country illegally when are
we going to admit that that's a crime
and and at least at least see it as one
on on perhaps a roll of one two three
unbelievable he was deported five times
and still here okay let's talk money
House Republicans have had it with the
cold shoulder from the president
although I think he's showing you
something quite different he's still
refusing to negotiate with you the House
GOP passed a bill laying out your plan
to cut rampant spending and raise the
debt limit as default is looming and
Republican leaders say it's all on the
Democrats and President Biden now let's
watch together
you guarantee as a leader in the United
States Congress that the United States
of America will not default on its debt
I I can assuming that our president and
the Schumer Senate uh recognize the
gravity of the problem the White House
needs to ultimately get into this
negotiation the president's been in
hiding for two months that's not
acceptable to Americans they expect the
president to sit in a room with speaker
McCarthy and start negotiating all right
let's just set the table Congressman
nearly a dozen house Democrats a couple
senators are splitting with Biden they
say it's time for him to sit down with
house Speaker McCarthy are those numbers
big enough to make it happen
well let's hope so I mean basically what
happened is Republicans called the
president's Bluff the president was
trying to bury his head in the sand he
was fiddling while America is burning
with rampant inflation and spending
money we don't have causing all manners
of problems for the American people and
we delivered we passed a common sense
strong piece of legislation that will
yes lift the debt ceiling but it will do
so responsibly by limiting spending the
very spending causing the inflation but
what is the president doing now he's not
just burying his head in the sand he has
basically set his administration out to
lie to the American people to go
fear-mongering to try to scare people
that were cutting veterans benefits and
and other programs but let's look at
what's really happening
OMB which reports the president they're
the ones that sent a memo to VA saying
hey they're going to cut spending even
though that's not true we're setting a
cap across the total spending level and
then the VA says we're cutting spending
but are they talking about the 80
percent of veterans who say inflation is
killing their budget and they can't make
ends meet the two-thirds you said
they're struggling how about the 70 25
percent of veterans who said we don't
like this student loan bailout because
we sacrifice for those benefits to be
able to go to school and now you want to
give it to somebody with gender studies
they're banning the pistol brace which
was literally made by and for veterans
this is all politicized operations by
this Administration we're delivering
we're going after corporate cronyism
we're ending the the dollar spending
that is causing inflation this is
responsible the president not only has a
duty to come to the table he's about to
be forced to politically because the
American people see what's really going
on yeah look and and as Republicans you
have basically put
him and he wants to point the finger but
he's the one who won't sit down great to
see you in Focus today thank you
great to you Harris God bless you you
too